so webinar is a version of R compiled to
run in a browser you might want to use
the containerization or sandboxing
abilities of a browser you might want to
run sort of literate Programming type
things where you weave software and
documentation together into a single
object or even reproducible output you
might have some data signs you want in a
nice package that is online or you might
just be interested in Universal binaries
the idea of running a piece of software
on lots of different machines I could
even be mobile phones or tablets these
are all great reasons
that I'm not going to talk about
today I'm going to talk about why I
wrote web art and it was actually for my
previous life as an academic
so when I worked for Newcastle
University one of the things I did was I
taught R to students and at the end of
the semester one of the things we do is
we evaluate what the students have
learned and we do that by asking them to
write some R code and we evaluate how
well that R chord runs
now during the pandemic we had to do
that in devices that we had no control
over people's home devices things where
I might not even be installed we even
had students doing exams very important
exams on a mobile phone which is not the
best thing to do
so the question was how do we capture
that R code and make sure they're doing
the right thing
our first idea was
um actually quite good we set a server
up that sits and listens for students R
code runs it works out what the answer
is and then sends it back so this way we
could give the student a website the
standard way of
um evaluating and assessing our students
works and we just plugged into it the
server so it sends the code away
remembers what the student did marks it
and then sends the answer back and at
first glance is really nice because the
students just writing R chord and
they're just seeing the results they're
happy so we tested it it worked we put
it into production and the first thing
that happened was the server crashed it
fell over and I had a room full of very
angry students
so that was not ideal um this was just
before the Christmas break so I went
away over Christmas and I thought okay
well what what can I do to solve this
and one of the ideas I had was to
instead evaluate that R code locally
inside the web browser instead of using
a server and this makes sense because it
means you're you're dividing the load
over lots of different machines instead
of depending on that one machine
so the way this works is that there's a
technology called webassembly that's
been around a few years now but is
getting more popular very recently and
what it is what it is is a portable
binary code format it's a bit like
JavaScript but when it's in a certain
format you can't read it properly it
runs in the browser
and what it does is enable high
performance applications to run in a web
browser at almost native speed
um it's supported by most modern
browsers and you can kind of think of it
as Java but good
the next thing that would make this work
is in scripting in scripting is a
compiler for a webassembly so it
converts C code into webassembly it's
based on llvm again it's been around for
a few years and successfully used in a
few projects dosbox and school life have
done it along with spoiler alert sorry
Winston
and also in scripting should work like
this you give it two commands there's
two commands em configure ear make you
give it C code and a webassembly package
falls out
what it works it's absolute magic it's
incredible uh it just works you you get
some C code and it runs online but
there's a problem
because our users Fortran code
some of the code it's inherited had
original releases that were in the 70s
and even worse
in script and can't directly compile
Fortran code
notice I say directly because there's a
trick
unfortunately the trick makes things a
little bit more complicated it looks
like that
I'm not going to go into detail it's
very messy there is a link there if
you're interested in learning more I
will point out I think I've got time
really quickly that there is a point in
that graph that says choose your own
chaos and that's because you choose
between using an ancient version of GCC
or an unreleased version of llvm so pick
your poison
it does work
um there's a website you can go to it
and you can run on the browser
I would say do it now but the conference
Wi-Fi is a bit iffy and it is quite a
big package that downloads so it may not
it may not work but when you get home go
to the website try it out you can all
packages I've built just enough of the
Tidy verse so that you can actually load
ggplot in the browser and make a plot
it looks like that uh and yeah it just
works
thank you very much
[Music]